major news out of North Carolina North
Carolina's republican-controlled
legislature has passed a package of
restrictions on the power of the
governor of North Carolina just in
advance of Republican Governor Pat
McCrory being replaced by North
Carolina's incoming governor Democrat
Roy Cooper Republicans in North Carolina
very very upset that the Republican
governor lost to Cooper and after weeks
of delaying Pat McCrory finally had to
say yes I lost I lost Cooper one and I
am NOT going to be the Republican
governor going forward but now outgoing
Republican Governor Pat McCrory signed
one of the two major bills that was
approved by north carolina republicans
this is nothing short of a political
insurrection attempt these bills would
strip future governors of their power to
appoint a majority to the State Board of
Elections the number of board members
was also expanded from five to eight
with the eight members being now uh uh
mandated to be evenly divided between
the two major parties Democrats and
Republicans isn't it convenient Pat that
Republicans think election boards should
all of a sudden be 5050 mandated just
before they lose control in the state of
North Carolina I'm sure it has nothing
to do with that yes has everything to do
with Republican it's obstruction ISM and
they're going to drag kicking and
screaming if they don't get their way
they absolutely are this these bills
also would change the state court system
in North Carolina making it more
difficult for the losers of some
superior court cases to appeal directly
to what is a democratic-controlled state
Supreme Court these bills make the
governor's cabinet appointees subject to
approval by the state Senate McCrory was
allowed to appoint whoever he wanted
with no Senate approval but future
Democratic governors and all governors
unless this gets reversed will need
senatorial approval and then there's a
second bill in North Carolina uh which
strips the governor of his ability to
name members of the boards of state
universities it also reduces the number
of
employees that the governor can appoint
from 1500 to 425 nearly a bigger than
two-thirds reduction the that bill the
second bill wasn't immediately signed by
Pat McCrory McCrory is really the worst
of the worst of the Republican Party up
there with kansas governor Sam Brownback
who destroyed the state of Kansas
McCrory is first of all a major liar and
I've mentioned this before McCrory
campaigned on the promise of not passing
laws that would restrict abortion he was
elected and he very quickly signs into
law one of those insane abortion laws
that requires abortion providers to have
the same uh stand meet the same
standards as surgical centers which is
it might sound like it makes sense but
it really doesn't when you understand
more about what abortions are non late
term abortions what they are uh and what
that would imply in terms of access to
abortion it also allowed providers
health care providers to quote decline
to perform abortions it prevented public
health insurance policies for paying for
abortion so the effect of this bill that
McCrory signed was in practice a huge
restriction on access to abortion but
when he was asked about it that people
rightly said hey governor you know you
campaigned on not passing laws that
restrict abortion and then you pass
these laws that restrict abortion he
said well no these laws won't actually
restrict access to abortion which is
totally bogus and i don't think i have
to remind most people in our audience
Pat the Pat McCrory was also behind and
a huge supporter of hb2 that ridiculous
transgender bathroom bill in North
Carolina this guy really is the worst of
the worst yet I think that transgender
bathroom bill is really going to tarnish
his reputation in the future because not
only was then just it's also going to
cost the state billions of dollars in
lost revenue yeah and to prevent his
replacement who won fair and square from
actually having the exact same abilities
that he did to do stuff so what might
happen with the bill will Cooper is
threatening to sue the legislature
voting rights expert Richard hasten says
yeah there's something to that uh some
of these changes could be challenged in
state and federal court do you realize
how insane this is this is effectively
political insurrection
what would happen if president obama
passed laws today just before he leaves
office and Donald Trump takes office
saying hey you know what all the stuff I
was able to do as president and prior
presidents were able to do yeah I'm
gonna change the law so that Donald
Trump is not able to do the same stuff
and this story is getting some coverage
but not the coverage it deserves and you
can actually you can contact pat
mccrory's office 9 1981 for 2,000 you
can also contact the Republican Speaker
of the North Carolina House uh that Tim
more at nine one nine seven three three
three four five one and you can say
listen if you don't live in North
Carolina say you want to business with
North Carolina businesses you won't
visit North Carolina if you live in
North Carolina say you're considering
moving out say that you would demand a
change here that you won't vacation
there if you don't live there be
whatever needs to happen these decisions
need to have economic consequences this
cannot be accepted today's show is
brought to you by godaddy where you can
buy your own domain name build a website
or use any of Go Daddy's business tools
you can save thirty percent at try
godaddy.com slash david go daddy has
actually been the official host of the
david pakman show website for many many
many years the 24 7 customer support has
been a very good thing for us I've
called them at really odd times when we
we've had website issues and they are
always available they are the largest
domain registrar and whether you have a
new idea you're an established business
you're creating a personal website or
moving your large enterprise site over
to godaddy they can do it all 13 million
customers try it and get thirty percent
off at try godaddy.com slash david